تحول اقتصادي للرئيس تركيا رضاان في اعقاب
الانتخابات التي سيطر عليها عنوان
الاقتصاد والازمات الماليه المتتاليه
ووعود جديده اطلقها وزير الماليه محمد
شمشك بالعوده الى سياسات اقتصاديه وصفها
بالعقلانيه بعد السياسات المرهقه للاقتصاد
التركي التي اتبعها اردوغان وفق الفاينشل
تايمزك اشار الى ضروره اعاده التضخم الى
خانه الاحاد على المدى المتوسط قرارات لم
تطلق من جانب احادي فيبدو ان الوعود التي
اطلقها وزير الماليه تمت بمباركه اردوغان
ليتخذ طريقا جديدا في معالجه الازمه
الماليه لكن تظل التساؤلات حول مدى مرونه
اردوغان لتغيير السياسات الاقتصاديه
للبلاد بحسب الصحيفه خبراء يرون ان اختيار
شمشك ليس مجرد تعيين رمزي بل خطوه للعوده
الى السياسات الاقتصاديه التقليديه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات